hey guys Greg knuckles here with the
semi daily string theory QA our question
today is how can I find my optimal grip
with for the bench press and I will say
just from the outset of this video that
this doesn't have an overly complicated
answer so don't watch this with the
expectation of just getting your mind
blown there is a pretty simple process
you can use to determine what the
strongest grip width will be for you and
one other thing I want to say before we
get started tomorrow we are dropping a
massive bench guide on the string theory
site so just keep a lookout for that the
URL will just be string theory calm
slash how - to - bench and it's gonna be
pretty awesome so if you want to know a
lot more about bench press check that
out tomorrow when it goes up so um just
to start with most people most of the
time find that their strongest bench
width is somewhere between 150 to 200
percent of their shoulder width of their
by acromial breadth so a chromium
process there at the top of your
shoulders so you know somewhere between
slightly wider than shoulder width and
twice shoulder width so that's that's
probably not overly surprising to anyone
and then also most world-class ventures
most of them not all of them but the
vast majority bench with the maximum
legal width which is 81 centimeters
that's with your pointer fingers on the
grip rings on a barbell so either that's
likely the width that gives you the
highest potential for strength increases
or just that most world-class ventures
are built in a way that allow that to be
the strongest position for them hard to
know which the causation really is there
but for you that that very well may not
describe you so very very simple process
you can use just start with your current
grip with how you how you typically
bench now and just next time you go to
the gym to bench work up to about 75 80
percent of your 1 rep max do a couple
reps with your normal bench grip then
move your hands in about an inch or two
try a couple reps there move your hands
out an inch or two try a couple reps
there and just kind of feel between the
slightly narrower grip and the slightly
wider grip which one of those felt
stronger and then for about a month or
two just your heavy sets of bench your
working sets just alternate one set with
whatever your current grip width is and
one with whichever one felt stronger so
let's just assume you know you bench a
particular way you try a little narrower
try a little wider a little wider maybe
it doesn't feel quite as strong as your
current grip width which should be
expected because it's not the width
you've been practicing with so you'll
probably not be quite as skilled with it
so maybe it feels about as strong as
your current grip maybe a little bit
weaker but it does feel stronger than
that slightly narrower grip you tried
for a month or two just alternate your
heavy sets with a slightly wider grip
and with your normal grip and then at
the end of a couple months if the wider
grip feels stronger than your current
grip does go with it and then
troubleshoot further in that direction
so the slightly wider grip is now your
your typical grip with and you know then
just try another inch or two wider give
that a shot for a couple months and then
just progressively see you know what
feels strongest for you just a process
of troubleshooting and optimization and
I will note a lot of the technical
issues that people ask me about a
similarly simple process works for them
so how wide should your feet be when you
squat pretty similar a start how you
currently squat try a little narrower
try a little wider and you know then for
a while just
just experiment with between those two
which one felt best alternate that with
your normal squat stance and if a slight
variation wider or narrower feel
stronger than go with that and then
troubleshoot again a lot of this stuff
really isn't rocket science and there's
no one-size-fits-all approaches you know
I like to squat really really wide and I
to some degree I need to because well
that's a long story my left ankle is
just wrecked beyond repair so very
limited dorsiflexion that I'm probably
never going to get back so I have to
squat wide just because my knees can't
track very far forward and luckily I'm
very comfortable squatting wide however
most people wouldn't be probably the
strongest squatting as wide as I do so
they need to go narrower you know
there's not one-size-fits-all approaches
and for most of these questions you know
so stance with for the squat should you
pull conventional or sumo should what
grip with should you bench most of these
things just a really simple
troubleshooting process is going to help
you figure that out for yourself and one
thing I will say the reason why I
recommend just trying slight changes so
you know maybe just an inch or two
different for for bench grip with same
thing for squats fans etc is that you
know you your muscles and joints are
used to a particular range of motion
they have particular length tension
relationships just based on how you've
been training to this point so by making
small adjustments that's probably going
to decrease your risk of having you know
something like tendinitis flare up just
from putting your joints through a range
of motion they're not used to placing
demands on your muscles that are
dramatically different than what they're
used to so you know start with what
you're currently comfortable with and
then just make little adjustments and
continue to do that every month or two
and just see what you're the most
comfortable with and yeah that's that's
the easiest way to figure it out for
yourself
I feel a little bit silly needing to
make this video but questions like that
are very very common they're probably
about a quarter of the total questions I
get I think people do think there are
one-size-fits-all approaches for for
questions and topics like that and
they're really just start just figure it
out for yourself
via gradual process of troubleshooting
so that is the video if you liked it
please like and subscribe and if you do
want to know more about bitchin beyond
just simple things like that that you
can troubleshoot check out the guide
that is dropping on string theory
tomorrow just string theory calm /how -
- - [ __ ] I think it's going to be well
I know it's awesome I hope you'll think
it is as well
and until then hope your training is
good hope you have a great day and I
will see you in that next video